listen okay you're spoiled I was 175
point - when we left Nina is going to
freak out
[Music]
what's up a leaf nation we're happy why
are we happy we're going home it's been
almost two weeks away two weeks away I
pronounce that weirdly today it's our
our last day we're not really doing much
here in London they just trying to hop
on our transportation get to the airport
and fly home how'd you sleep last night
Nina not great me neither not great
we're going to have a long night because
we're five hours ahead so we're going to
try to stay up as late as possible
tonight to get rid of the jetlag as much
as we can so we're gonna get to the
airport get some coffee
it's our last junkie eating day what are
you gonna have Deena I'm gonna see what
I see it's windy look at Nina's hair
look at my hand it's all over the place
okay okay I gotta help carry the bags
we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before we could check in we have to get
our taxes back from those shoes that we
bought or Nina's friend at least we're
here early we can get it done yeah yeah
all right that was actually pretty
pretty painless pretty fast
no lineup let the pay a 5-pound fee to
make that happen and they converted the
Canadians I'm sure they took exchange
but whatever that's what you get Tony so
I just thought didn't take a long time
we're gonna we're gonna check in we're
gonna check in boo boo boo boo boo boo
get on our plane all right we made it in
time to find the lounge and relax
[Music]
they're swapping out breakfast for lunch
we get a whole new set of food options
amen whole new set of food options
I see marshmallows and Smarties even as
a carrot it is in your phone he is doing
Facebook
what's Nina do alex is asleep look look
what look at the marshmallows and
Smarties behind the marshmallows and
Smarties listen okay you've spoiled oh
is that vegetable soup they have there
is that vegetable soup they have them in
a container on the soup vegetable soup
[Music]
followed quality lunch right they're
reviewing videos making it for you guys
it's what I do in my downtime
all right done with the videos for now
got some good work done we are getting
ready to find our heat board keep 44
let's go Bob
lean that we're going home do that color
for matching look at that
Oh Mac insurance yeah Nina sees the docs
and mrs. tema
[Music]
it looks like same deal as last time oh
wait what the seat works
last time need a seat didn't recline
okay so we'll see if he passed out on
the way I feel I feel like you will 7
1/2 hours he was gonna fall asleep same
deal we got the bag toiletries are
probably the same listen to their
headphones and glass of water
big TV although I think it ended up
working most of the time I hope his wife
on this plane because I have videos to
review you guys not I might just report
a couple videos hopefully not to serve
the people around me
and get some content done for you guys
Cheers
safe flight home
[Music]
all right so there's no Wi-Fi on this
point very sad it's gonna be a late
night I'm watching
going to videos
to get it to my team so we can get it
that you guys
another day
[Music]
all right we made enough how you feeling
did you sleep you slept I think this is
my first flight in maybe all year that
was no delay on the way back I'm addict
the exaggerating but I feel like it's
the first flight all year that I had no
delays because Nina was with me yeah so
more of the story is bringing and with
you on flights all right well good to be
back here in Canada good tea oh it is
sunny it is warmer than anywhere we've
been on our vacation welcome back to
sunny warm Canada it's amazing
we're gonna go through customs hop in
uber and head home I have to review
videos for the channel because we had no
Wi-Fi in the airplane there gonna be a
bleed tonight and I have to get Timo
paid no Wi-Fi no yeah it's gonna be a
late 90 plus for five hours ahead so
it's gonna be a really late night like
10 o'clock our time is gonna be three
o'clock but we're actually healing so
I'll see I'll try to get it done as fast
as possible
but I got to make videos here for these
guys Nina
these guys need good videos so I got to
put in the work right you guys need
quality to watch I'm gonna put in my
time
all right here we go
[Music]
alright that was the fastest we've ever
been through customs the fastest even
through customs although they did
questions $600 a pair of shoes didn't he
didn't like that although it was more
than that dislike 700 right us yeah oh
my god as soon as we pulled up listen we
both had the we both have the branded
shirts on he looks at it's got a big
smile he's like believe and like believe
you got to make the customs people smile
they can make your life hell if they
want to
[Music]
all right just got back I miss this
place the believe headquarters yeah
alright just put the stuff down still I
gotta take off my sweater not even gonna
unpack just getting straight to videos
for you guys I'm thinking of taking a
quick break from looking at videos to
weigh myself I was 175 point to when we
left let's take a walk to the scale walk
to the skin with me people 175.2 190 4.3
[Music]
20 pounds and how many days 13 days Oh
Nina okay okay I got a distance serious
weight loss I can t not calm step on 9
so you gained 12 pounds and I gained 20
in the morning I know I know okay listen
guys 10 pounds of this at least this
morning wait
anyway we got it we got to get healthy
we got to get back to healthy back the
healthy food this week
[Music]
whoa who's this guy all cleaned up so as
I was reviewing the videos my nails sort
of bother me and then I realized I
haven't cut my nails in a while before I
left and so I said I can't got to cut my
nails and as I was doing that doesn't
need to cut my hair and do a shade so
there's all once feeling clean and I'm
ready to get back to work
look at this place it's a mess
whoa look at this guy who is this
clean-shaven human being it doesn't hurt
alright that was the surprise unit oh I
can't go back to mo oh go get Timo Louie
our friend has been looking after Timo
and so I gotta go pick up Timo and then
[Music]
who's that who's that it's people it's
team oh hello mister hello mr. t whoa
what a spaz
[Music]
Louie from last-minute training here
last-minute training dot CA go check it
out yourselves training Hey gonna take
the mo home Nina is going to freak out
John stop he has fun right John's have
action well we're going back to sleeping
during the day Timo okay go sleeping
during the day we're home Timo we're
home Timo we're gonna go see me now
let's go see Nina come on let's go come
on let's go see Nina
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right well thank you guys for
joining us on our vacation on our trip
the multi week series for you guys to
tune into Nina what was the highlight of
the trip for you right it is good
right again yeah it is good meeting a
nice meeting at the hovering the herring
having the herring the ring maybe
appreciated the Sun nice I liked it the
rain made me appreciate the Sun more and
coming home and seen this guy yeah
how cute is that guy cool well thank you
guys for watching hope you have a great
close to the weekend we believe in you
we hope we continue to in yourself and
whatever is much love guys we'll see you
soon female say goodbye say goodbye Timo
[Music]